e
I wonder if I could ask um just to make
I think I know the answer to this but
other than the issue of the um the uh
exemption for the part-time uh
um uh assistant director of SEC Safety
and Security for the judicial branch my
understanding is that there's no changes
on any of the other things that the the
house and Senator are can are fine on
all the other all the other Provisions
is that we're fine with the bill as we
no no no I I understand I understand
we're good I think you all have the
issues over there so what can we do to
help you right the issue is with regard
to the assistant uh director of Safety
and Security for the judicial branch um
and I I wonder before we get to the
discussion if if I could just ask Mr uh
Carin if he could just just give us a
brief overview of how the retirement
system works with regard to the judicial
branch and I I had a couple of questions
based on our our caucus discussion and I
guess the first one is is the judicial
branch oh yeah could you come to the mic
sorry is is the judicial branch
participation in the retirement system
for non-judge employees is that
something that is is created by Statute
or was that something that's just or
sort of historically existed it I as a
as a branch of of government it's it's
um it was it's they've always been
included as far as my knowledge they
weren't added later you know the
non-judge uh courts judicial branch
employees okay but I mean my question do
you know is there a statute that
actually says that or is that just you
know that's just sort of historical
that's the way it always
was I I would have to look in the Statue
I believe that you know that they would
fall under the state employee umbrella
you know which state employee uh you
know is mandatory membership for
full-time permanent position so I I
don't think it was you know it's a
different branch of government but nhrs
is also even though we're not an
executive branch agency we we fall under
that state
employee uh you know
eligibility oh for enrollment okay all
right um
and the other question I have and I'm
not I'm not sure M Carlin if you would
be the person that would be would be
able to answer this better or perhaps
someone from the judicial branch would
be able as I understand it um per DM
court security officers
are exempt
from uh for lack of a better term the
provision that prohibits double dipping
so that in other words a retired a
police police officer could retire
collect the group two pension benefits
and then become a pum court security
officer is that yeah PDM court security
officer and PDM BFF as well I'm not I'm
not sure what the distinction is in in
in the judicial realm for those those
position titles but either of those
positions that that is correct those
those two exceptions perm uh court
security officers and BFFs um were um
added when when the working after
retirement statutes were put in into
Statute in 2011 in House Bill 2 um prior
to that we referred to our
administrative rule for the definition
of full-time and anything less than that
was part-time and there were no
Provisions or limits on that as long as
it wasn't a full-time permanent position
so when hp2 put the first statutory
definition of part-time and what was
allowed in the statute those positions
were carved out I think it was during a
committee of conference um on on that uh
those aspects of the bill okay and and
so am I understanding correctly is if
someone
is a um a perdm security security
officer or
bayth are are those persons allowed to
work the equivalent of
full-time yes uh provided that they're
they're not doing it every week you know
once once you know there's you know
there's there is a a smell test if
you're regularly scheduled to work
full-time hours regardless of what
whether it's called PDM or not we would
probably look at that and say that's a
full-time job um you know but if it's
truly Prem even if it's a couple or
month of full weeks in a row but it's
not a permanent position regularly
scheduled to work that many hours they
they're they're exempt from the hourly
limits okay then I have just one other
question and I throw it open to anybody
anyone else who may have question
questions is um my understanding is that
the the legislative branch has
essentially Exempted um itself from
having uh employees have to
participate full-time I I have to
participate in the retirement system my
question
is my understanding is and I'm asking
really to know if this is correct is
that the overwhelming majority of
legislative
employees do participate in the
retirement system that and there was
with the ex as I understand it with the
exception of a few people who might be
characterized as really having sort of
political positions that they're going
to be there only as long as whoever
their elected official boss is there
those people might not participate might
choose not to participate but most
almost everybody else does is is that
your understanding that that's my
understanding I don't I don't have
specific data to back that up but just
anecdotally over the last 15 years you
know the the career employees you know
LBA legislative Services folks tend tend
to be in the system you know um and it's
it's more you know governor's office
policy positions in the majority offices
in the House and Senate those folks who
may not see the position as something
they're ever going to vest in so they
choose not to to to join when they get
get appointed or hired to those jobs
okay all right I I don't have any other
question question anybody else have
questions for Mr car I just want to
clarify you mentioned up until now we've
just been talking about judicial and um
uh and legislative but you did include
uh the governor's office employees is
that correct yeah yeah that yes that
yeah that that that's also we we've
interpreted that as is you know an
executive branch office it's not a state
agency per se so we we've allowed that
optional membership uh for folks serving
in the governor's office as well and
what about the Secretary of State um I
think they that would fall under
optional membership as well um so I I'm
sure there's some some folks who are
retired over there who um are working
there and collecting a benefit because
they chose not to join in HRS when they
were appointed to those
positions thank you so you know I'm
sorry can I any other questions can I
just ask one other question so in my
understanding from what you've just said
is
that the bottom line so to speak is that
the legislative
branch has a
few people um who are who are not
elected officials but you know provide
services to elected officials who are
able to double dip yeah the governor's
office the executive branch at sort of
the height of the executive branch can
do the same thing
but the judicial branch as things now
stand is the only branch that doesn't
have the ability to do
that the answer is yes but I I I'd like
to condition that if I may
representative Smith's question raised
another point it's not just whether a
specific position is um not all
positions may be optional like your
example of the secretary of state that
would fall under the official appointed
for a fixed
term uh position so like if you know
anybody who was at a senior enough uh
you know position or the position was
defined as a fix term appointment that's
where the optional comes in as well as
you know Rank and fr you know General
Court employee so in in context of this
assistant um director position that the
bill um that's issue in this bill that
the director position is not a fixed
term appointment so it would
be POS potentially hard to make the the
assistant a fix term appointment if the
if they're B isn't but you know that
that fixed term appointment piece is
also allows optional membership you know
under the
law sorry in in my mind the phrase
double dipping is a
pejorative um and for those of us who
were continue over a long period of time
to be concerned about the financial
stability of the retirement system
double dipping is definitely a
pejorative but double dipping does not
apply does it to all the positions we've
talked about except those people who are
uh from from the police or or fire yeah
it's a term we don't tend to use at the
retirement system you know you know in
general because there are different
opinions on what's defined as double
dipping you know some people would look
and say anybody who's collecting a
pension shouldn't be working for state
government in or a governmental entity
in New Hampshire and that's one position
other people look at and say well these
are positions you're allowed to under
the law so you're not you you're not
you're not doing anything wrong this
you're you're entitled to do that so
that you know that that to to your point
yeah that's you know that's there's a
definition definitional issue I think
with some folks on what agreeing what it
is Senator Carson thank you Mr chair
um what what this bill is is asking us
to do is not atypical we get and I've
worked with Mr car for a number of years
um we do get these requests usually it
revolves around security because it is
difficult to get trained individuals to
do this kind of work so everything is
done on a Case by casee basis where a
piece of legislation is filed it goes
through the legislative process and we
make the decision whether or not to
exempt them and that includes um
individuals that might be um uh
nominated and uh confirmed as uh a
commissioner usually I think the last
one was uh Mr Plumber who was retired
and what he was asked to come back and
be the director of Homeland Security and
so we had to uh go through the
legislative process for an exemption so
what's happening in this bill is not
atypical um this was a request of the
court and and this is what um this is
what they need so it's up to us to
decide whether or not we want to give
the exemption but I want to make the
point that these kind of asks are not
atypical um we do get them in Edna from
time to time and they go through the
legislative process and the legislature
makes the decision whether or not to
exempt and that's exactly what this bill
is trying to do representative goalie
and then representative Smith thank you
Mr chair Marty isn't the director of
Homeland Security a group two position
uh it it is yes yes it had been in group
one for a while and that was also a
change somewhere along the line so um
you know Senator Carson's right there
there's been some some tweak with with
that specific job but it is a full-time
paying position into the is a fulltime
unlike what this position it's a fixed
term appointment so a future nominee
could opt to not you know be in the
system but it is a full-time permanent
and uh one of so you know can I just can
I just make sure I just want to F can I
just follow up for a minute so my
understanding that the the although the
current director of Homeland Security is
is in group two am I understanding from
what you just said that a a future
person who might occupy this that
position after the current occupant
leaves could elect could could be a
retired police officer for example and
elect not to participate in the
retirement system yes because it's a fix
term appointment you know you know that
goes through the governor and Council so
there there's a there's a you know fixed
sorry is there any way and I understand
probably not but that this position that
they're looking
for could be a group two position and
just because of where they're located in
the
courts um I think I think I think I
think it's a part-time position intended
to be so I mean it it would be kind of
moot in that sense in terms of
Eligibility if there were a full-time
position you know there are definitions
for a permanent police permanent fire
and other um uh other definitions
Correctional offic of certain probation
officers things like that so
definitionally you know certain
positions have been added to group two
uh sometimes I recall an instance where
I think it was a forests and lands fire
prevention Bureau or something where the
the legislature added that you know if
the person was if if someone was hired
who was a group two employee they can
stay in group two if they take that
position so there's again it kind of
gets back to Senator Senator Carson's
points about that there have been sort
of Creative Solutions to specific issues
over the years some that have flown with
both bodies and some that haven't so
this can I yes of course so this
position
has if it be if it was a full-time
position we could write into the statute
a way of someone who is currently in
group two working either as a state
police or police officer
somewhere to take this position as a
group two position yeah and maintain the
group two status yeah that could be done
yes thank
you represent Smith could I just ask a
related question
um it would also change Court
bails that you know that we um a couple
weeks ago we got a got a um a version of
the amendment when it was going uh to to
the Senate and looked at that and our
legal folks um and I agree with them saw
that comma placement you know in the
break there as potentially turning all
Bays into they can work as many hours as
they want regardless of retirement
statute and our attorney uh apparently
spoke to the attorney one of the
attorneys at the judicial branch um that
that was the request of the drafting
that was a that you know the the OS was
pretty Wanted It That Way um what we
would do with that and it's probably
good that I'm you know saying this in a
meeting uh you know our our legal staff
has has told me that if if that we would
prefer the and and then a comma for this
one position but if it went through as
as we would continue to interpret it the
way it was um you know as as per DM
court security and prum balas but
wouldn't it be more accurate um uh to
use what I
old-fashioned refer to as the Oxford
comma and have the comma there to make
clear what the intention is I we we and
HRS would suggest that so would say
perm Court bis and Security offices
comma and the assistant director of and
just keep keep that that thought you
know to string together the perum with
those two positions as it is now you
know thank you very much and and I have
just one other minor question um well no
go I I'm thank you I'm looking at this
and it says online 23 but accepting per
DM court security officers comma crosses
out and and then it says Port bayts
comma and the assistant director so I
think that that's correct you know what
but you know no I think what I think
what what um he's saying is this if you
if you leave the wording the way it is
in the Senate Amendment it would
mean
um uh could me could mean uh but
accepting
perdm court security
officers and Court Bays I I'm sorry it
could mean perd perdm Court court
security officers as one
category Court
BFFs as another category and the
assistant director and so that could
mean that Court
bfts could
be categorically accepted even if they
were
full-time whereas if you left it to read
but accepting per DM court security
officers and Court Bays that would mean
per M court security officers and per DM
Court bailers that's what it effectively
would mean so Mr chairman are you making
the proposal that we um put back the
word and and take out the comma and take
out the comma yes that that I mean I
think that would that would solve the
problem that was the issue that we would
that clear that up for you if we yes it
would I I have I I don't think any would
you guys agree with this then if we did
that yeah well well agre to that that
that that that c moves it in the right
direction 20 minutes we be like boom
boom you've got me for about five more
minutes me too we've got another one so
here's you know I
guess the issue IO I think is this and I
and perhaps I'll let one of my
colleagues can articulate it better
because I I'm gonna just tell I'm GNA
just be very up front with you
I'm I understand my role here is to
support the house position and in the
end I will do that but I am very
sympathetic to what the Senate has done
here because I have to say
honestly my concern is that we what you
what the Senate has done makes sense to
me because we have we have a system
where for example as I understand it we
just had the the the legislative branch
just hired an assistant director of
security who is retired is a retired
state police captain and will be able to
double dip
and I'm not I don't mean any pejorative
term on that at
all I have a hard time understanding why
the judicial branch can't do the same
thing well chief justice is here that's
why I think the chief justice is here um
no I'm because if and I don't mean to
speak for the chair of Edna but this was
a request that came in from the court to
the Senate so that's why we included it
so uh it makes perfect sense to us I
think think the problem is you have one
person who has served on Edna and the
rest of you haven't where we all are and
we understand this and especially me
because as I said we've gotten requests
like this and we've given the exemptions
um they're very usually very extenuating
circumstances so um the court is here
and I think perhaps Mr chairman it would
be good to hear from them why they need
this yeah yes but I do want to do I do
you want to hear from but representative
golden please thank you Mr chair and yes
I have been around in with Edna for many
years and you know I just got to I need
to respond that we've
had over the years I've been there we've
actually reduced the number of hours
that our retired Personnel can work
we've had numerous times where Police
and Fire Chiefs have come forward
looking for us to increase ours because
of the help they've needed and we stood
firm on that over the years um we may
have had a few exceptions but I think
one of the exceptions I look at when I
do it is
we've both the house and the Senate as
we look at it have taken firm positions
on the number of hours you work after
retirement whether it's a police chief
or Fire Chief and I'm looking at the
solution as we've done it with Homeland
Security and all the other ones is
allowing that individual become group
two which we just heard Marty say it
could be done making that a group two
position where someone transfers over
just like per plumber did over to where
he did and allow that person to continue
working and paying into the
system going forward and it's a group
two position from there on out and
that's where my argument is where we
should be going not exempting another
employee and taking someone off when we
tell all these police departments and
fire departments we won't allow you to
do that with your Chiefs I don't think
it's fair to them
and and if I could just add one thing
Senator I understand your time um it is
that although I haven't been on Edna I
have been on finance and I know the
incredible problems that we have with
the retirement system because of the
unfunded liability that we have been
struggling to address and so from that
point of view I have concerns um about
opening up um a rabbit
hole you know can I just add I wonder if
uh chief justice McDonald I wonder if we
could just if you could just give us a
couple of minutes to just explain why
you think this is so important to uh to
do
this thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Gordon McDonald I'm
the Chief Justice and I understand the
Senators are under time constraint but
I'll be
blunt my number one priority is ensuring
this Safety and Security of everyone who
walks through our doors every day
hundreds of people in more than 40
locations around the
state litigant the public members of the
media our 800 staff and and
judges the threat environment that we
are facing is
complex and it's
immediate and everyone in the judicial
branch felt deeply
about the events at New Hampshire
hospital we have a courtroom in that
facility we mourn the loss of Chief hos
but more directly to the state court
community a state court judge in
Maryland was
assassinated in his driveway last
October Judge Andrew
Wilkinson the threats out there are
numerous they are complex and we need to
do all we can
and literally what keeps me up at night
is this that question are we doing all
we
can and that is why I'm here today that
is why this is so important to to me and
the leadership of the judicial
branch we've started a number of
initiatives with respect to training and
equipping our court security officers to
en fortifying our uh facilities but we
exactly what this exemption is asking
for and that's Decades of experience
from State Police that the state has
invested in we want to leverage that so
it's double dipping in a different sense
it's leveraging that experience and what
do we need it in threat
assessment cooperation with State local
County and federal law enforcement
increasing our physical safety in
enhancing our training retention and
recruitment that is why we need this
exception and to the chair's Point we've
been working closely with the
legislative leadership working in tandem
we are asking for nothing more than what
the legislature has done in appointing a
full-time assistant director of Safety
and Security with the kind of background
that the legislature has uh found and
kept in better and we found in our
employee and I just think as a matter of
comedy and respect for the judicial
branch and what we think we need to do
to keep people safe in our facilities I
would respectfully request this
committee to concur with the Senate
Amendment Mr chair in the interest of
time we are going to have to run here
soon I I think I can speak for all of us
saying we we're willing to make the
technical change that you wanted to but
I I think we're going to insist that
this language stays in the bill we're I
mean you kind of know where I'm standing
but I'm I'm wondering where everybody
else on the house side stands sure I as
I said I I I I I want to emphasize I
don't for a
minute poo poo uh or or discount the
concerns that uh representative goalie
and representative Smith have have said
I I understand and I understand that you
know we're making an exception and I an
argument can be made that every time you
make an exception you know you make it
harder to to uh enforce the rule I I do
understand that but I think I mean I
think that the chief on the other side
of this has a pretty good argument that
you know we maybe it maybe hiso maybe
you know in some at some point in the in
the future we we ought to consider you
know some kind of restructuring of the
of the judicial branch so that they have
exempt employees um or that kind of
thing or per or uh people appointed for
a specific term maybe that would make
sense you know so that so that the
exceptions uh that might might apply in
that circumstance would be this would be
analogous to what currently exists in
the legislature but that's an to me
that's an issue for another day I I tend
to think that the chief has made a
pretty compelling case of why we ought
to do this now and could I ask
course thank you so much for being here
Mr chief justice um tell me what the
problem is um with having
um the gentleman you've identified come
into this position which we all
recognize as important as a full-time
group 2 employee what's the problem with
that I think there's a separation of
powers problem to my knowledge we have
no group two employees group two are
executive group law enforcement is an
executive
function we provide court security in
the courtrooms that is a completely
different function than what is
discharged by group to employees which
is generally law to my knowledge law
enforcement fire protection safety our
our our goal in establishing this
position is to bring the expertise that
former law enforcement has to the
special and unique need needs that
judicial branch has in providing Safety
and Security so you want the training
you want the experience you want the
expertise um you just don't want him to
have to comply with group TR two I I
want parody with the legislative branch
to be completely blunt and I think I
think the judicial branch the judicial
branch has identified this as a need and
and the legislative branch has an
exemption under 100
A7 and this is the same need that we
have as a separate branch of government
and I I'm I just respectfully would urge
the legislature to exceed to what the
leg what the Judiciary is asking for
here you know can I just make one other
comment you know I had I have to say I
had not even thought frankly until the
chief just mentioned this about the
about the the group the separation of
powers issue but I think that is I mean
we do
we as I understand it correct me if I'm
wrong Chief the the the court the court
security even R even Line Court security
officers are not group two employees
because they're not Law Enforcement
Officers that's correct they are not
sworn law enforcement that's I mean
that's another to say you know it's we
we don't I think what the chief is
saying and I think I agree with this
completely we don't have the option of
doing
of of amending the statute in the way
you suggested representative goalie
because we would be making we'd be
creating one law enforcement officer um
in the judicial branch in a position
that I think is
inconsistent the judicial the judicial
branch doesn't have Law Enforcement
Officers presumably this law enforcement
officer would be subject subject to the
direction of the control of the chief
justice so that makes no sense under our
system of
government Mr chair we're going to have
to either recess this or come to an agre
realt so let me ask you I mean let me
ask my colleagues where where they
are and I have no problem in recessing
this if we need more time um but I'm
just wondering
where think the of the
situational threats there I've been
moved support it with with the one
so
let's so let's do the let's let's recess
what no no no I understand but I want to
have I I think I want to have a
conversation with the speaker before
before I make that question what are
your schu what's uh what does it look
tomorrow's pretty open for me or you
trying to do it today
um all right quickest I could do would
be 11: a.m I've got three back to back
bang bang yeah me too soon as I could do
would be 11 uh you know what this uh
this after I mean
um oh you're not here at
11:30 you could you hang around till
11:30 I have CU that'll give you time go
to speaker whatever else you need to do
11:30 11:30 is that 11:30 does that work
for you yeah all right all right so
we'll recess to now what do I have to
do just recess it recess 11 recess all
right so I'm going to recess this
hearing until 11:30 a.m. all thank you
everybody'll and thank you uh thank you
chief justice and
and uh all Witnesses who appeared here
thank you thank you Mr chairman members
it you're on 1585 y I'm headed down this
to
e
and I believe um uh I'll let everyone
else speak if they have something to say
I believe have come uh the house is uh
in agreement now with the Senate version
with the one change of the comma that we
that we talked about um and so um I I
called OS and told him I asked him if
they could draft so they said they
probably weren't going to have it ready
by SE by 11:30 but um they they will
draft something which will be the Senate
version of the bill with the one change
to removing the comma and putting the
word and back in okay um is that um am I
speaking correctly for everyone in the
house yes house house agrees to that the
Senate agrees as well y we appreciate
your good work I know we appreciate
yours as well and I'm glad I I
appreciate the witnesses being here I
think they were they really Mr chairman
you had a very
introductory introduction to the state
retirement system as
well well I know I know some think about
I mean our my retirement system is a
little different it's very small but
it's the
same I'm in the new I'm I'm in the new
one I sit on the judicial Retirement
Board so I know how that one works too
I'm I'm I'm in the new one I had a I had
a choice and I actually yeah voted so I
think we're good I'm going to adjourn it
thank you thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman thank you all right and so
you know what just a quick qu so I I
will get the report and then we we we
have to go up to the uh Clerk's officer
or right sign it or you can ask um if
for example if it's not ready if you're
not going to be
here someone else ask somebody else to
sign you can ask person have to ask
office okay all right all right great
hey thank you very much all right bye
right
e
okay I'd like to go ahead with this
Committee of conference it is 1:00 uh
and these things are scheduled kind of
tightly here um so we're dealing right
now with HB
1265 uh this this is a bill that deals
with relative to the penalty for failure
to file School expenditure reports
relative to certain adequacy grants and
requiring mandatory reporting by school
districts of school
expenses and does everybody here have a
copy of the side by side that Jennifer
for provided yeah great okay so what
we'd like to do is you know we have a
house version here and a senate version
we'd like to go down
and and try to either you know present
where we are on our positions uh I'll
open up first to representa cordelli do
you have an amendment that we're
ours uh yes I do and it uh is an
amendment to the uh language that was
Senate basically the uh Senate added
um what had been I believe it was Senate
Bill
219 um on to
1265 and um we made it uh this amendment
with a couple of changes to what was
added um in the Senate um the first
edition uh uh that you'll see on lines 3
through five is related to the cost per
pupil which is required to be uh
displayed uh we made this change so that
it's consistent with the Department of
Education uh
calculation uh strictly for consistency
purposes um and in the
calculation is added that the
expenditures for tuition
transportation and food operations not
supported by public funds are excluded
from the calculation of cost per
pupil um still in the um in the language
um will be uh
options uh B and C um and that this is a
a good faith effort uh by the district
to arrive at the um cost per
pupil okay before you jump on any
further with your
if we want to discuss why we did this
that there are school districts you all
have to report on your annual form the
do25 form and they break out food
service and transportation separately
some districts when they look at this
incorporate those costs in so we're
trying to get a consistent figure across
the board for all districts so District
a right beside District B is reporting
on the same data uh so that that's the
premise behind what we're trying to do
here
okay thank you Glen yeah um and as I
said still are um uh points B and C and
that this is a um reasonable and good
faith estimate and uh the uh amount in
good faith by the Department of
Education um responds to uh to a which
we just
amended the um the other
changes uh go down to um if you're
looking at
the um I'll try and look at the uh side
by
4 which is on um page
four and what we changed here was we
added
that uh some administrators employed by
the district may be contract
employees um that was a suggestion from
the Department all these changes were
worked on with the Department of
Education the other
day so um this would be salaries paid to
administrators imp employed or
contracted by the district and the same
or contracted is added in Roman 5 in
terms of the employees
uh salaries the administrator
salaries um one other change there
you'll
see in Roman
4 um it
says
um employed by the district
corresponding School administrators unit
over the previous 10 years we added in a
SE a sentence which reads on
year Amendment administrators serving
multiple districts may have an
annotation showing how their salary is a
portioned between multiple
districts so if um you know working with
the Department we felt that uh if it's a
shared position um the district should
show their share of the employees
salaries so go ahead again so the idea
being that if I have a principal at
servicing two two schools in a different
in different District they have 50% time
in each you would annotate his salaries
$100,000 $50,000 of this district and
$50,000 of this district has an
annotation on the report right thank you
and that is common in some places in in
our
saus um and the only other change to the
Senate language was the uh effective
date we changed it from January 1st to
July 1st uh to better align align with
the um uh Gathering of information from
fall and we do have mark
from the Department here if you have any
questions on this Mark Mone is was
working with the LBA before he went over
and decided to cross town right Mark do
you have any
questions I don't have any questions I I
think that um several these changes make
some good sense and I don't have that
much objection to it all um Senator Lang
you have any uh questions or concerns
about the change to lines four and five
so again so I think we're talking about
the again going I one of the things I
was get ready to defend was why we added
this bill and talk about transparency
fact that I went to go pull up just from
wi my home district ms25 and try to find
the administrative salaries versus
anything else and it was not an easy
task and I served on the school board um
for for for six years so um so that was
the intent of the bill is to make it
clear to the voter those kind of things
that are extremely important to the
voters um so and I understand again they
do on that form specifically carve out
those expenses separate and and so it
makes sense to me that we're talking
about the actual educational expense in
terms of classroom expense not
necessarily food and transportation
so um with these amendments it still has
the district has to do a graph and post
it yes all that's the same remains in it
so that's assuming that districts have
the capability of of doing those graphs
and posting them in all these places and
is it taking into account how much time
that will take each district to
do so we recognize that it's it's uh
going to be uh an increased workload to
some extent but again given this isn't
somebody with an abacus and a piece of
paper trying to Divi Define something
again these are all digital graphs
that'll come out of excel um with the
input of the data and the data is All
Digital to begin with so this isn't this
isn't days and weeks of labor nowadays
this is hours at most and again the
question is weighing out those couple
hours against the transparency needs of
the voters to understand budgeting and
budgeting is occurring I think it's a
good use of of time to educate the the
people who are paying the bill and
followup yes and this is this isn't just
easily findable on the Department of
Education website it is not it is there
it is not easily found I just spent I
just spent the last 30 minutes trying to
do my one school district to try to see
if I could easily pull out the
administrative cost and the things that
were interesting I wrote notes on if I
can find My Notes now um was you know
they they group things in general into a
single line says general Administration
so you don't know what it is unless you
then go get the the actual district
report to that reports the salaries to
figure out which falls under which
category they they put things in codes
100 1200 1300 1400 again unless you went
back to refer to the original report to
try to dig out thing that even the
information on the doe websites not
detailed so if someone went to doe to
pull up the report would then have to go
pull up the local district report to
figure out where people fit you know
they have a a a simple single line item
that's School
Administration in there doesn't detail
any how many positions that references
or anything else on the doe website you
would have to then go back down and
figure out which category by looking at
the book I I think it's easy for us to
lose sight of the fact that our voters
are not CPAs and they're not policy
people they don't necessarily serve on
the budget committee right and and they
just know what their tax bill looks like
and they want to know where it's being
spent and so the idea being this makes
it more transparent and easier for them
to see where money is being
spent further comments from the
committee represent courel and it still
leaves in the um civil remedies so any
taxpayer in the taxing district who is
aggrieved by a violation of this Chapel
May petition the court for
amendment so again in this instance
under the Civil remedies there's no
costs associated with the Civil remedy
what it is is it the judge ordering the
district to comply and the district
would then have to
comply and they be subject to any
attorneys fees if they had to bring it
this because the district refused to
comply with the with the law um they
would be able to recover their cost back
for having the sue the district to force
them to comply with the
law we have uh debated many times uh
about um the requirements to get uh
whether it's a school district or other
agency to comply with a a law that we
passed and uh we've said that uh you
know perhaps we need more teeth in some
of these statutes um and this is a a
mild step um uh in terms of remedies
um it's often said that uh uh a law
without teeth is a is a suggestion so uh
I think this is something um that is uh
really needed for transparency for not
just the voters but in many cases uh
Schoolboard members uh might be
interested in this information also when
they're contemplating the budget you
know it's it's amazing how some
districts are providing this in their
annual reports others are not
and and so the information has been
available my concern is it even goes
deeper than this is that um we've been
asking for years specific data what are
the actual costs of an adequate
education and we always reference this
do25 form which is loaded with all kinds
of stuff internally and and when
districts are dividing their enrollment
into that and coming up here's the
average cost well you might be dividing
into the marching band which is not
inadequacy
requirement and I've been told over and
over and I think this is occurring and I
hope Mark you can say yay or nay that
that Caitlyn's very much aware of that
and we're working at trying to get a
breakdown on how the adequacy items are
related to that doe2 form and I know
several years back we as a house put in
monies for an an analyst to work with
Nate over there $140 $160,000 that never
made it and if you need staff to help
out doing something let me know but I'm
I'm real concerned that I want to go
deeper than just this information about
our instructional Personnel I want to
know how dollars being
used great could we take a two- minute
recession so I can confir my colleague
yeah yeah confir on that amend it yep
that's we'll talk about okay good enough
and we'll do the same thing okay um you
can use one of the offices here and
we're going to do the same thing we're
here
e
uh open up the meeting again for
1265 and I think we're at the point
where we're going to make a decision
we're running on the time here uh
represent Cordell I'd like you to make a
motion for the house
side uh yes I'd like to um make a motion
that we um
concur uh or seed to the Senate uh
version with the addition of amendment
uh
2213 H okay so on our side we have a
recommendation uh a motion to approve
the Senate version to concur or I I say
a seed to and with the amendment 2213 h
on on the house side all those in favor
I I I okay so on the Senate where are
y'all so where again I think we have an
i an i and a no and she's asking to be
replaced from the committee conference
so we'll have unanimous on the sen okay
so we have unanimous consent yeah thank
you
e
uh next uh Committee of conference which
we have on a docket for today and this
is relative to HB 1616 and act relative
to the parentals consent for student
participation in the Medicaid to schools
program and establishing a pilot
recruitment and retention program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services so we have here in front of us
I hope everybody has the side by side
which shows the house
version and the Senate
version and I'm going to start this
thing out because I do have one haunting
question I'd like to know uh from the
Senate conferees that are sitting beside
me to my
right um for whom is this pilot program
going to
serve to whom is going to receive these
Grant monies um is it all people in HHS
is it a select group
within the receiving institutions
whatever can you let me know sure
absolutely thank you for the question so
I I draw your L your attention to the
bill as amended uh line 25 which talks
about the intent right the intent of
this act is a proactively address
vacancy rates FL situations experienced
in census populations and Acuity care
and Reliance of contracted staff at the
current cunu Youth Services Center and
at the secure treatment facility to repl
uh to replace the um senu Center so
again this is Hamad hospital it's
dealing with staff there to act as a uh
retention recruitment to keep people at
those two youth youth facilities because
we're struggling to have staff there so
it's being used for those three two
actually two two actually youth center
and the Hamstead uh facility yep that's
it so it's a retention program for those
two youth programs um that retain staff
staff are there other
questions uh does anyone know um the
funding from this would that have to be
approved by the fiscal Comm committee at
this point that's correct it would be an
off- budget request that would go in and
they would have to uh request it up
fiscal
right further questions yes represent
Bon um I I didn't see on here what is
the amount um that you're looking
for you want second I'm going to have to
go back to the original bill but I don't
recall the amount I think if I remember
right this was coming out of arpa funds
um if I remember they were going to be
dedicating some arpa funds what nope
hold on we have AGS they they can answer
the question how much it was I don't
welcome good afternoon members of the
committee uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services um the purpose
for this request is to continue the
Recruitment and Retention program that
currently exists today at syc um that
statute is expiring uh June 30th 2023 um
the provisions in this bill would
continue that for a period of
approximately 1.25 years
um the purpose is that
syc has uh struggled with vacancy rates
relativ to the youth counselors we have
had to pay out I'm projecting about $4
million potentially in overtime this
year as well as contracted staff there
um they've offered a recruitment and
retention program where if staff work
three shifts in one twoe period um they
receive a $300 um stipend um that has to
date allowed us to avoid in recent
months mandatory overtime uh which from
a morale perspective is certainly not
beneficial the funds for the syc portion
um those are paid out of the existing
syc budget um through vacancies or other
transfers into that account which would
be approved through the fiscal committee
process and then for
Hamstead the department recently went
back out to bid um and we are entering
into a contract with Dartmouth Health to
take over the facility and there's a
fairly substantial adjustment to how the
operations are going to look we're well
paath traditionally hired um
approximately 170 staff in the state is
has been engaging in a process to bring
those staff on board and the department
is in our intent is to ensure that we
can continue to provide the Recruitment
and Retention incentives that have
existed to date to ensure that the that
the facility um is not impacted in any
sort of negative way and the the quality
committee yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you um and so you're say I know
that this had already gone through one
another without this we wouldn't the
state wouldn't have the flexibility that
we need in order to keep the people have
put on you know 10 15 17 19 years of
service at Hamstead Hospital
in order to make sure that we're able to
keep them in the community providing for
some of our most vulnerable kids um the
provisions the hb1 1236 Provisions
there's two Provisions in that this is
one of them and then the second being
the the language that you're referring
to here that language is not included in
1616 but the other language mirrors a
recruitment retention but with without
um that recruitment retention language
um we would certainly be be concerned
Rel relative to our ability to ensure
that services are not diminished and we
can um recruit and attract and retain
staff appropriately thank you it's
absolutely
vital any further questions from any of
the committee
members you need time nope if you're
going toed to the Senate position I
don't need any time we need time are we
I don't have an amendment there's no
Amendment on it would be the Senate
version that's on the side by side right
now and
I sign I have an issue with the
voting Mr chairman yes um it was my
understanding that members of the the
conference committee need to support the
how the body's position so if there's a
concern on the underlying understand how
that works do you have a question
regarding the bill though that is of
concern um yes um of the original
bill or of the
amendment we're voting on the bill as
amended it would
be um so um my position on the original
bill is that um I feel that uh parental
consent is already provided and that
this uh bill um will take away the
flexibility that uh the federal
government has already entitled school
districts to have in terms of getting U
Medicaid payments uh directly to the
schools and that schools currently can
be reimbursed for 50% of the eligible
costs and without having that
flexibility in the billing process uh it
could actually be more of a burden on
the local taxpayers in terms of getting
that money reimbursed um and already
within the system there are plenty of
opportunities uh where the parent does
have to sign consent the services cannot
be given at all to the student until
there is a parent parental consent form
signed uh there is an original parental
consent form to Bill Medicaid and it is
uh reviewed annually and it can be
withdrawn at any time so I feel that
those Provisions are already taken care
of and with that I will not be able to
support
it any further comments yes if if I may
I I don't want to repeat what the
representative just said but I have the
same concern um particularly regarding
lines 10 through 13 um so as long as
that portion is still in the amended
version um someone would have to replace
me to sign off on the report I can't
any further
comments okay is there a need to caucus
on either
side yeah so then the folks which are
will be removed from the house side and
the same on okay so
um uh repr L where are you on this um I
support the full Bell so I'm ready to
assed to the Senate yes
and I the same so there three supporting
as amended by the
Senate we'll have two two
okay so with that we are closing down
this Committee of conference it's uh
okay thank you
grant hey Grant on the previous Bill we
need sen of apprentice swap back
too uh the
yeah
e
uh next and last uh Committee of
conference we have for today this is
relative to HB
1665 on act relative to student
eligibility for Education Freedom
accounts and the scholarship
organization's costs of administering
the program extending phase out grants
for Education Freedom account and Revis
ing the definitions of average daily
membership in attendance and average
daily membership in
Residence so I'd like to go ahead we
have uh
a a sheet which was passed out to us a
side by side which shows the house
version and the Senate version if we can
let's try to work off of that uh so
we're on the same page all of us so with
that I will open up this conference for
committee meeting for comments represent
cordelli
thank you um I think that the house
position is a strong uh position uh for
a family income cap uh increased to 500%
of federal poverty and I just like to
read a couple of sentences from a recent
article in the Josiah Bartlett um public
policy um newsletter and part of it rain
pertains to the recent uh Court ruling
about um uh
anti-discrimination uh it says on
Tuesday US District Court Judge Paul
Barbaro ruled on constitutional 21 2021
law legislators passed to prevent public
schools from indoctrinating staff and
students in ideological doctrines that
classify groups of humans as Superior or
inferior to others based on inherited
characteristics um on the same day as
that ruling
um three of four Republican incumbents
in the Texas house lost their runoff
elections um they had been opponents of
school choice in Texas last year so I
think something like a total of
14 anti-school Choice house members in
Texas have been defeated um since uh
last fall um then again on Thursday
Louisiana passed a universal education
savings account and I think that makes
it the 12th state to adopt Universal
esas and further from that article I
point out that in New
Hampshire 66% of adults and
74% of parents support
esas so the article closes with this um
judge Barbaro signal to parents this
week that there is no recourse should
the government use public schools to
Advocate controversial doctrines
Louisiana showed us that recourse would
look like what it could look like Texas
signal what happens when lawmakers
failed to provide it so I think from
around the country um Louisiana Texas
Idaho uh where they had a host of uh
anti-choice legislators uh defeated in
the last election I think that we've
seen um uh choice being a very strong
position with uh parents uh and families
and I think that um the house position
of 500% of federal poverty uh is um a
good position and uh is desired by the
families of New Hampshire thank you are
there further
comments go ahead
follow thank so the obviously the Senate
position is 400% of poverty um the
reason uh we're we're at that um is
again the and the additions we made to
the bill was 400% of poverty is equal to
uh around 24
$124,900 for a family of four which just
happens to be um 400% of the FED federal
poverty line so what it says is that
again the median income for New
Hampshire and Below would be subject to
um all uh being available for Education
trust fund dollars um we also agree that
um Schools and
Government doesn't turn on the dime um
and that schools need time to adapt
their budgets to any lost students that
are in there and so because of that
we've added um the uh phase the phase
out grants uh into this to extend the
phase out grants to allow school
districts time to adapt to the red
reducing
um reducing populations acknowledging
the fact that we we said even when we
started phaseout grants that we were
going to we recognized that issue and we
um we created the phase out grants the
reason we're extending this further is
because again we acknowledge we're
changing the conditions of efas and
therefore and and making more students
eligible for efas in doing that we need
to allow again allow schools that time
financially I don't see that as a um as
an issue in spending and the reason
being is that we currently pay phase out
grants um the M vast majority and the
last time we upgraded uh this in the
300ish students took that and a portion
of those students were public school
students subject to phase out grants
those students are coming on their third
year and be dropping off phase out
grants public we won't be spending that
money at the state level for those
students that no longer exist in schools
but now we are changing the the the
formula uh going to 400% there will be
students we just want to be able to
continue to provide the same safeguards
we did for public schools in the
original outline for these new students
that are rolling in allow schools to
have time because we know government
doesn't turn on a dime um and they need
time to adapt and adjust to the uh
reducing enrollments for students that
are eligible um so for and and and and
paralleling that we added reporting
mechanisms within this bill to make sure
that we know where the money is going as
it relates to those phase out grants
what schools are getting them how much
they're getting um what the costs of the
districts are going to be so I I think
again the Senate position is pretty
straightforward I think uh it it governs
of the uh again 50% our median income
and Below um supports those families
that need that money available to them
and the choice so the Senate's going to
support the
100% okay uh further comments
yes representative Cornell I I just
wanted to point out that this is not a
budget year and the fiscal note says
that the that this cost would be
indeterminable and that it could be
approximately over $2
million um and in a non-budget year I I
don't think we should be
um saying we're going to spend that
possibly that much money um many other
bills have come up that people have
spoken against saying in a non-budget
year we shouldn't be spending more funds
and I agree with
that further
comments representa Bradley yeah let me
just add that Senator Bradley yeah
that's fine excuse me that's fine I
answered to anything sepy being a Yankee
fan um in terms of the last comment
about spending money we've already spent
$60 million for the YDC settlement in an
off budget year it's on its way to the
the governor we've already spent
26.7 million for a group two retirement
fix that's also on its way to the
governor so um it happens I think we
have to be somewhat cautious in seconde
spending uh there are a lot of smaller
bills I didn't bring that list but there
we are generating some Surplus um we've
utilized arpa money for some things for
instance Hampton Harbor five 00,000 to
start the dredging $2.5 million that
actually you folks voted for for uh
shelter in Manchester and some of the
other shelters that's likely to be ARA
money but it could be General funds so
um anyway that's what we've done just
this year
alone Senator AER are you wanting to
speak to got you read uh yes thank you
um so as with regards to the seconde
spending it's the Senate's position is
400% of the poverty line is something
that
um we
are not necessarily in the greatest
position to absorb but are prepared to
absorb and
um perhaps you know there is some
consideration from our colleague from
Tuftonboro to factor in election year
issues but that is that is not what is
on the table right now um what we are
talking about is keeping the 400% of
federal poverty lines and and figuring
out how we are going to um how we're
going to pay for that in the first place
and um what what is important that the
Senate has put in its version is the new
section that directs the Department of
Education to submit a report so we have
a little bit of an idea of how this um
cost is being absorbed within the budget
um we're we're we're not in a position
to be throwing 500% poverty
um okay into this bill at this point
Thank you I'd like to chew into it a
little bit more than Beyond just this
400 500% uh issue uh on on page three
it talks about a a a student who rece
receives an EFA May attend grade 7
through 12 and the school which they're
attending would receive on behalf of
that child or student a 0.15 pupil uh
pupil teacher you know uh dollar sign so
um that we do for homeschooling where
they do not receive the the any kind of
support financially for Education
they're clear of at all so we do
reimburse the high schools for that and
it's now we've extended it to grade
seventh and eight um is it appropriate
question I think representative lad the
Senate thought it was a good idea um I
think we are far more committed to
making sure that we have the phase out
grants um we thought
that some EFA folks are potentially
taking advantage of this and it would be
a help to the school districts that's
how we saw it that by giving that what
would it be about $600
$650 0.15% of adequacy would just
similar to the phase out grants it would
help the school districts if somebody
took advantage of it so that's why
is the Senate really attached to that
item uh it's seen by some on the house
side quite a few in fact even the
members here in the committee that the
dollars that they're going to receive
are on top of the dollars the students
receiving for the EFA the $5,200 or
whatever it may be uh is that close or
nearing double dipping so again you know
we can talk about that we can go to a
committee and and caucus and talk about
that on the sense side but again the
idea was was if you were to spend that
money at the public school side that is
that much more money available for the
parents of an EFA to be able to provide
education on the other five subjects
that classroom subjects that a student
would be eligible for um and potentially
get better Education Services because
they're not paying a tuition to the
school instead um but we can talk about
that on the Senate side and see where we
think we want to go with that we were
nodding to the school recognizing that
knowledging that Nea course say high I'm
going to use high school physics might
be really tough for a parent to teach at
home um and so they want to send their
kid to the school the school needs to
provide services for that classroom so
it can either be done through a tuition
or we can just have them qualify with an
extra one 15% of a of a FTE position for
a student um and have that uh money be
reimbursed through the normal education
trust fund we we were trying to support
both the parents and the school but
we'll be open to have a conversation
about it and see how committed we are to
it actually uh we thought you folks
would like it right exactly right
exactly right we had discussed it and we
took it out because it's not for a
course it's for each course they take
yeah no I so it could compound I think
that if we can come to resolution on
some of the other pieces of the bill we
can come to resolution on
that represent cordelli yes um leading
up to this meeting I talked to some of
the other members of our education
committee on on our side of the aisle
and I think um well besides the uh
family income cap I think the U main
item of concern uh to them was the phase
out grant
extension um and I heard it
expressed uh that um we shouldn't be
paying for ghost students students who
are no longer in in the public school um
so I I think that that is sticking Point
um a couple that I uh talked to um was
you know willing to um
negotiate or willing to bend a little on
the um uh family income cap if there was
to be a phase out Grant uh for instance
um if it was 450 plus the phase out
Grant um I I know a couple of them that
I talked to would be willing to to go
along um with that um but there were
others who would um not be willing to go
along with uh the
400% plus the phase out grants the that
was really a a sticking point um for a
number of
people so again we we'll talk about that
um we'll bring it back into in a senate
caucus but I just remind the house
members that's exactly what you voted
voted for when you created the um
program was to allow a phase out to
allow students as they move out and
again I I think ultimately it's going to
be a revenue neutral position because
we're in our third year of efas which
means those students who were eligible
for the phase out grants in in our first
iteration of this program are now
phasing out and not spending any of that
money um and so it's a it's a revenue
neutral position as we change from 300
to 350 now to
400% um we're going to introduce new
students into this mix and allowing for
those same students to have the same
eligibility as the first on 300% I think
is pretty important to everybody
but we'll take it back and consider it U
speaking of um taking to caucus and
compromising um I did uh prepare an
amendment um that I think had the
support of um number of Republicans on
our committee um that would be for the
400% but removing the phas out Grant it
would be the
400% plus the reduced administrative fee
to to
8% um but just those two components were
in the
amendment take a recess yeah we can
recess but I would just say that um one
of the things that a lot of senators
have told me
um that has really been precluded by the
indefinite po postponement motion is
income verification and I think for a
number the Senators
um as the income threshold goes up and
we went from 300 to 350 where we're at
now it becomes more and more important
for income verification so we're forced
to accept that is off the
table um so that's why I think senators
are like really kind of dug in on U Bas
out
grants it's too bad that they are dug in
so entrenched um I can remember another
type of program which we entrenched
ourselves back in 2011
stabilization it took us over 10 years
to dump it uh and you know so it's hold
harmless stabilization is supposed to be
a step ratcheting down um I get it and I
understand you're also Senator Bradley
your your perspective and where you are
so if we can work on trying to get into
caucus here and and try to come back
with some ideas it would be appreciated
is is there any further dis your red
lights on again
there recommendation just go okay so
we're going to go caucus right now we
have two officers right outside where we
can go Cox and just grab one and we'll
opposite
e
okay we're ready to go ahead and
continue at 1665
um I'll come back and I'll offer the the
senate members uh where we
are um if we're going to deal with the
phase out we'd like to see a phase out
for two years not three years and with
the
400% we'd like to see
425 and the 0.15 taken
out so Mr chair what the Senate's
position would be is to leave section 1
2 3 and four uh as they are written um
and strike section five which is a 15%
and reum six to five uh that would be
the Senate position and you'd have yes
votes right now on that I said if we
want if you want anything else I think
we would uh ask that we recess and
reconvene
tomorrow okay we're going to CAU us for
you just like Committees of conference
I got his education in
off
e
what we like to do is
um recognizing that we we didn't have a
good reception for raising that 400 and
changing the phase out uh we like to
recess and come back tomorrow morning if
we
can I looking at my schedule I have a
nine a 10
then a 1:30 a 2 3:00 meeting with the
chancellors a 3:00 trustee meeting in
the afternoon it goes to 6 so the only
time I can do it is late morning or
during the lunch hour is
too well do you want uh
I I if not maybe you can let me know and
we well we got to schedule it so yeah go
ahead
11:30 or 11 do you want to do a little
ory
to
okay we we we we'll set up for
11:30 so with that this meeting is
you you're going to be around and allall